how's it going breath my name is beer
back we just killed a giant caterpillar
thingy it's really late this time around
when I'm recording so I think it's
perfect for this thing all right more
dragon things - dragon demon spawn high
higher than Carly Carly
Bobby I love your tits early night I
can't even see them that's a nice job
and the visible tits are my favorite
that's why [ __ ] that seriously I didn't
save the last episode because I'm
[ __ ] stupid about the replay this but
don't worry about it
[ __ ] dragons what is that anyway
Jesus Christ
alright alright alright alright alright
[ __ ] is this that's not gonna be open oh
right in the face
I can't die now I have three of these
I'm so far I wish I knew where to go ed
leave nope right buck [ __ ] your dragons
alright we're almost at res we're almost
there don't even worry sink you sink
your eyes shut don't dance now I always
keep telling them don't dance when
there's dragons in ground but no ow I
might actually have to kill this little
[ __ ] oh great now that monkeys raping
monkeys dude oh and dogs cool cuz I
didn't think that was enough
alright what have we got over here
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] oh yeah
alright the [ __ ] are we do we even have
we have a map are we going back to the
hospital is that it I guess so
that's all I can think of maybe we can
meet Lisa again or whatever I don't
[ __ ] know yeah I guess all right I'm
round Lisa it's your birthday happy
birthday Lisa to the left to the right
dodging dragons all night alright
alright should be here hey dragon are
you doing dragons later noobs know it
[ __ ] Wow
not today dragons come on please work
whoa hey doggies please be a save here
please to be a save here I think we're
actually returned to this [ __ ]
hellhole I guess we're not done killing
the killing the [ __ ] boss in here I
just don't like this I just don't really
oh we haven't watched the tape yet maybe
you can watch the tape now Lisa what are
you doing here glad you're okay I'm glad
you're okay girl thank God you came back
I was scared to be here all alone I
would never leave you all alone don't
worry man I was worried too mmm-hmm
really happy to see you Lisa can you
tell me how to get to the lake well you
haven't either got a lake the BOK
commander Oh buck uma the roads blocked
then why do I dance the only way out
there it's got to be another way there's
got to be another way
exactly there's always another way this
is slightly down wait I just remembered
something please follow me because I'm
dying to know there's a waterworks over
by my old elementary school Oh nuts
school it's been abandoned for years no
I'm not going there
under inspections or something
underground tunnel it runs all the way
to the lake you think I can get to the
lake from there I'm pretty [ __ ] sure
myself so I'm not positive don't worry
about it and stop to keep people out
well that's even better there's a chance
I've got to try
[ __ ] we're scared breath sorry don't go
I know you're a scared girl I'll be back
it's so scary I can't stand it how about
coming with me she can this may not be
the safest place in the world either I
can't promise you anything but I'll do
my best to protect you no somehow I feel
I'm not supposed to leave this place all
right
Oh Harry I'm so scared I'm cold
just wait here a little longer now let
me kill all the dinosaurs back as soon
as I find my daughter
all righty Harry what
right
what what oh he just left
Wow poor girl that's horrible
all right so now we got some intel on
Lisa Lisa is your birthday happy
birthday Lucia all right so let's go to
the elementary I don't want to [ __ ]
go there I really really really where
did the dogs go what is this music oh I
don't like this what the [ __ ] what in
the hell
all right please don't be dinosaurs
please some to be dinosaurs okay this is
actually worse than dinosaurs what the
[ __ ]
okay I'm kind of [ __ ] creeped out
right now we can go there
oh we can only go up yeah
all right what is going on oh there's
gonna be a boss fight I just killed a
caterpillar
please don't oh [ __ ] me what the [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
I hate butterflies my girlfriend saw
this she would freak out oh [ __ ] what am
i doing up here I regret everything I
want to thank my grandma and my mom for
making me live but that's oh [ __ ]
alright alright alright what the hell we
gotta kill this thing I can do this I
can do this I'm a grown man almost [ __ ]
how much ammo do we have alright alright
it's caterpillar pooing in the face time
hey how you doing now shoot me hey how
you doing hi ru friendly request just
kidding stupid [ __ ] alright alright
alright alright
tactics oh no those [ __ ] don't shoot the
air that's a bad tactic very bad tactic
alright he shot one that means I can
shoot some at him no don't hide behind
that thing you little [ __ ] boom boom
boom oh [ __ ] me I want you in my room
let's spend the night together and John
I went to forever boom come here God Ron
Ron thank you thank you thank you you
are great Harry
boom boom boom boom
I want to [ __ ] our cutter plume and then
I want to plume it I decide from Friday
night don't kill me
bad caterpillar you're not even a
caterpillar you're it oh I get it
oh I get it it all makes sense now
I can't do it yet your [ __ ] duck
aren't you
your backtick make my life miserable how
can you miss from there it's [ __ ]
huge don't kill me bro I really got it
yourself now cool cuz I have so many of
these this is fantastic
will you please die I'll give you my
pokemon card collection just kidding you
can't have it but anyway but you can die
okay Mobe yes son of a car
mow sucka my duck I don't even have one
I just lied I keep lying to you I'm
sorry and that's why you want to kill me
because you know that's okay lying is
bad that's what I've heard
Atlee how does that feel can you even
die well it bleeds it please so I should
be able to kill it
come here bruh come on brah
no not today mr. caterpillar yes that's
right I called it caterpillar what you
gonna do about it huh what you gonna do
about it why are you so angry bruh wait
they're hybrid oh dear huh huh did your
mama not shave your [ __ ] for you is
that it sighs why are you angry good
because that doesn't make sense
and neither does your face hahaha all
right I'm sorry you don't get me all
right Bo [ __ ] me I'm gonna die from this
piece of [ __ ]
what am I even doing here what am I even
doing what am I doing with my life
get out of my goddamn it all right go
down
fine then going down are you happy now
what is your deal
lineage god damn I hate you all right
and we're gonna go to plan B and I don't
like I don't really like plan B because
I don't think it's gonna work
what's going on over here oh [ __ ] all
right the traps I get it I got it how's
it goin how's your family cool okay
how's the Doria oh [ __ ] all right that
should have been an obvious maybe we can
like destroy this silo thing I was Plan
B for me but you know I don't have many
plans sir all right all right hey catch
blue glitter I know your name is not
exactly
oh don't kill me sir Sam don't see why
in the heavens that I think that was
gonna work I'm so [ __ ]
all right plant plant looper this is my
last house back by the way I just want
to point that out it's gonna be
fantastic
don't even worry about it I totally know
what I'm doing you don't think so well
have you ever killed one of these things
before
oh you have oh [ __ ] that looks like it
does a lot more damage I bet he didn't
like that oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he did not
like the shotgun oh [ __ ] is angry and
means we can kill it
oh [ __ ] me yeah and your bait and your
face [ __ ] you your giant little cat
pollute catalytic and political hurt
care for the kind of blue caterpillar
the catalytic alert catch up with the
car to put a pointer poor that was
awesome we totally killed him I wanna
eat a sandwich can Lisa please make it
to [ __ ] where can I go there alright
that was pretty cool thank you brother
thank you alright so we could go up it
magically repeat itself that's quite
nice quite lovely alright today let's go
back downstairs and then the dog is he
good getting sick of the dogs and [ __ ]
man
alright so our plan is to go back to the
hospital just really quick really quick
see see we probably should go back there
else today I [ __ ] let's do it anyway
I just want to save after that boss that
was a difficult oh [ __ ] dog is good
all right I just want to say really sad
it's your birthday happy birthday
lee-char
all right that hello Doggett it is
they're like the most persistent [ __ ]
monsters in a game ever all right so I
think we need to go back to the left
there you see two old silent L we need
to go ahead to their life like Beyonce
always said she taught me a lot of nice
things you know she say you two go to
left and everything you own goes to the
left and yeah let's keep following this
road a little more while I sing the try
to be a little [ __ ] it be
now let's do another song with Beatles
Hey Jude don't make hey Harry don't make
it bad take a sad song and make it
better
[Laughter]
remember to [ __ ] ah then you will start
to make it bad
I press gotta end this episode here we
teleport it wow I actually want to save
us some time that's nice
alright so that'll be a perfect way to
end this episode how do you brother stay
awesome
you